In Avengers: Infinity War, the evil
villain Thanos likely draw inspiration
from Malthus. Like Thanos, Malthus was
convinced that population growth would
outpace growth in living standards, leading
to disaster.
Unlike Thanos, Malthus did not use a
magic glove to kill half the universe.
But Thanos and Malthus are wrong. As
technology improves, so does efficiency.
Earth's population has grown
significantly over the centuries, but
calories are more available, and extreme
poverty more scarce, than ever before.
The key reason? Efficiency and
productivity gains, and innovation, allow
living standards to grow faster than the
population. Instead of delivering death
and destruction,
Thanos should focus on increasing
productivity, innovation, and efficiency.
Specifically, he should encourage rule of
law, strong liberal institutions, and an
entrepreneurial culture. Break down trade
barriers between planets and galaxies.
Deregulate businesses. Lower the
corporate tax rate on each and every
planet. Patent reform! And, of course,
generous funding for scientific research.
Here's hoping the Avengers stop Thanos
in the next film. They are on the side of
the best social and economic analysis.
The internet tells me that some of you
think Thanos did nothing wrong. Why? Let us
know in your comments. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.